tout a commencé par la création d'un
groupe facebook il ya quatre mois
guyancourt objectif ville propre réuni
200 personnes
ses habitants se retrouvent une fois par
semaine pour ramasser les déchets
présents dans la commune on trouve un
peu de tout mais quand je vous dis tout
ça peut être de gros encombrants on a
ramassé deux tonnes d'encombrants
c'est à dire des meubles des pneus une
poubelle des années 70 donc des déchets
qui sont là depuis très longtemps ou des
déchets très récents gants gilet
fluorescent gels hydroalcooliques pince
les bénévoles ont pu s'équiper en
matériel de protection grâce à des
partenariats avec des commerçants de
guyancourt 28 litres de déchets ont été
ramassées depuis quatre mois en fait ce
qui est désespérant plus je m'attendais
à des déchets mais je ne pensais pas
qu'il y avait autant de gens qui la
civilité c'est le fait de jeter ses
détritus par la fenêtre
quoi donc des fois il ya des fourrés et
on retrouve les boîtes du mcdo on
retrouve les bouteilles de coca
ces ramassages de déchets sont aussi
l'occasion de passer du temps en famille
et de se balader avec les enfants je
viens d nettoyer pour que la ville soit
propre
enfin le playback pour peut faire
défiler contre lestoille et la ville de
ria très jolie valérie tellier qui gère
le groupe facebook a été convié à un
groupe de travail par la mairie pour
l'organisation de la journée autour de
l'écologie klingbeil qui aura lieu en
septembre